we're going to go on to the empowerment
project we actually have three programs
implementing empowerment in Connecticut
quite successfully but we chose one to
talk with you today empowerment is a
community level HIV prevention
intervention for young gay men so unlike
3mb that works in groups this run really
works at changing the social norms of
the entire community so it's a community
level intervention targeting those
social norms it's developed by and for
young gay men and a lot of these
interventions actually are I think I
heard earlier that DD up was not but it
actually was it's an adaptation of pol
that's developed by and for young black
MSM so there really was a lot of input
into these from the target population
themselves it uses formal and informal
outreach discussion groups creation of
safe spaces social opportunities and
social marketing and I think there is
misconception among other providers who
don't work with these interventions
about what they are really about I've
heard more than one person say oh those
people are just having a bunch of
parties and actually having parties as a
part of empowerment and and it's all
that social stuff that you heard stuff
and talked about earlier so the theory
and the evidence behind it it's based on
a theory of diffusion of innovations and
what that theory states is that members
of social systems adopt new behaviors
when they see their peers adopting them
as well so it's very social and the
evidence was that it significantly
reduced unprotected anal intercourse
specifically was what they measured
among the participants core elements I
should mention all debbie's have core
elements those are the things about the
intervention that cannot be changed
because it's what made the intervention
successful so when we're talking about
core elements for empowerment it's to
regroup a core group of gay men to
design and carry out the activities of
the intervention to establish a project
space where your activities can be held
conduct entertaining venue based
outreach by teams of young gay men so
you are partying
sponsor social events to promote
community building among the gay men and
then convene peer-led one-time
discussion groups where that's where
your prevention stuff is going to come
in and conduct a publicity campaign
about the project ok so now I would like
to ask Samuel Bowens he is the HIV
prevention coordinator at the Waterbury
Health Department right here in
Connecticut so talk to you about their
experience with empowerment righty good
afternoon everyone in June of 2009 the
Waterbury Health Department implemented
our empowerment project also known as
the M team and the guys joke with me
sometimes because the first event that
we did I called it the a-team I was
having a flashback of one of the old
cartoons back in the day but they are
called the M team and it stands for
motivation teamwork education
achievement and of course empowerment
this is a flyer that the core group
members have come up with our
empowerment program core groups meet
every Wednesday at the water berry
health department from one o'clock two
three o'clock this particular
intervention we felt was well overdue
and needed in the greater Waterbury area
to date there's only one gay venue which
is a straight club that does a gay night
on wednesday night we have met with one
local high school gay and lesbian
program and which is predominantly
lesbian membership increased numbers of
identified MSM seeking services through
the water berry health department
red-flagged to us that there was a need
to implement such a program as the
empowerment program thus Evelyn Morales
who is the water very health department
at the time she ran both departments
care and Prevention Program and she
recruited me at that time I had worked
with the water berry health department
for a couple years because I had on the
local business it was a bar and I had a
lot of insight so I thought what was
going on in the community where the guys
were hanging out and what the cool
things were to do so Evelyn and I kind
of built a great relationship with each
other and she felt that I was the person
that could make this come alive because
of the context that I had with the
community not only being a gay man
myself and being proud of being gay but
having a very good rapport with some of
the young gentleman that I work with
throughout the Waterbury area mentoring
per se because I didn't have that
growing up in my early gay years and
having someone that was focused on not
just the party scene and just out having
a good time with you there's nothing
wrong with that that's a cool thing but
my focus was to relay to the young
gentleman that there is so much more to
being gay and so much more that you can
use all that energy and focus on some
more the positive positive things like
educating each other and spreading the
knowledge of safer sex and HIV awareness
this was one of our first empowerment
meetings that we had as I stated before
we just felt that there was a red flag
and we definitely needed to reach out to
the rainbow family so we implemented
this program on june on june of last
year and we're coming actually this
month is our one year anniversary we're
educating them on empowerment
requirements goals and recruitment on
techniques elena i sat down with the
care and prevention programs and we
educated our staff members so that they
would know what empowerment was all
about so when they came in contact with
identified MSM through CTR or any of the
outreach community events that we were
doing that they could definitely give
them a brief description of
it was all about and then send him over
to my office and I can go a little bit
more in detail to them about what it was
empowerment was all about as the team
began to recruit through CTR street
outreach and bars apps our outreach
recruitment provided proved to be
effective and successful our first core
group meeting consisted of 12 adverse
excuse me diversed members strong we had
a little mix of everybody so when we
talk about the rainbow family there was
definitely a rainbow of young gentleman
very interesting enough we had a
transgender that came to us and it was
kind of heart-wrenching that she really
didn't know where she fit in and I spoke
with Vivian and says you know the
empowerment program is about educating
and protecting and supporting each other
and we need to find a way to make this
person fit so we gave her a shot and her
name is Tatiana and she has proven to be
very effective she is one of our
strongest outreaches when she goes out
to the community let me tell you she's
not afraid to approach anyone she gets
the message across she can tell you from
A to Z what the water very health
department does what the empowerment
team is all about and she's just proud
and happy to be a part of the
empowerment team as I stated before the
attendance was consistent and the core
group members were excited to learn some
of our recent these are just pictures
here of us just having a good time at
some of the core group meetings
some of the some of our greatest
successes I should say to date is uh I'm
just trying to move here to the slide I
didn't realize I had so many pictures
here it just goes to show you that we're
having a good time you know and the the
team is serious about what they're doing
this here was an event that we did we
had their called the watermelon crusher
a local dance group and the girls
actually the young lady in the center
there her mother works with the
Waterbury health department and they
came to me and said you know we just
want to be a part of what you're doing
my mom has told me so much about your
program and we have a lot of friends in
school that are gay and they really
don't know where to go and you know this
would be great for us to just be a part
of what you're doing so we thought it
was really cool idea the success that
arm is so great right now I'm is that we
recently were approved to advertise with
water Barry bus transit effective next
month this ad that you see here is going
to be spotlighted on all the buses now
all the buses but quite a few buses
throughout the city of Waterbury they'll
be on the sides and on the inside of the
bus line so we are excited about that we
have found that on changing the venues
from the Health Department versus you
know the whole health department thing
kind of scares and deters young people
to coming to something that is really
cool and can be beneficial to them
therefore we have implemented on movie
nights every third wednesday at the
Waterbury library and what the guys do
is they get together and they they show
a feature educational MSM theme title
movie they have refreshments and they
sit down and have group discussion and
they just talk about what's going on in
their community you know what I mean how
they can help and support each other in
april of this year we bought on Sylvia
Sora's
to join the empowerment project and he
is our new program facilitator his new
ideas his experience unique and
innovative teaching techniques have
brought new excitement to the members
within a three week period like anything
you know I always joke with the guys and
say you know Howie and I'm talking from
a nice statement gay people you know if
there's a dollar holler you know when I
was in the bar business I said they're
just not supporting me you know what I
mean every time a straight bar you know
goes and has a gay night you know
they're all over there and I've got the
same three people sitting here you know
what I mean and drinking you know to me
and it just like we're not we're not
dedicated you know what I mean and he
brought the numbers from a low 52 back
up to 11 members strong so that's where
we're standing right now with our core
group so I applaud him on just a short
period of time getting the guys together
networking going out into the community
and an increasingly awareness of what
empowerment is all about we have three
members whose attendance has been
impeccable and one of the members are
actually here today Jared Hayes he has
not missed one core group meeting since
we started from day one and I think when
you see numbers like that and people
might say well only three guys are only
five guys that have stuck it out from
the beginning in a year's term you know
I go by an old saying that my
grandmother you should tell me where
there's two or three in the mist you
know what I mean and it proves that when
you have guys that are willing to
dedicate their time and their knowledge
and their experiences and pass that on
to the next person and pass it on to the
next person and pass it on to the next
person well you know what then it proves
that this intervention works you know so
happy about that we keep prog weekly
progress notes on each individual in the
core group and Sylvie and I get together
on a weekly basis and we review the
progress notes and to be honest with you
we've come a long way in a year's time
change behaviors are evident you know
what I mean when we sit down and talk
real real life situations with each
other during our core group meetings the
guys are more
what they're doing and like I told them
from the beginning you know we're not
trying to wash your clean as snow and I
mean what we want you to do is be aware
of what you're doing and if you're out
tricking three or four times a week and
you wear a condom one time that's harm
reduction you we're being effective it's
working you know what I mean and what's
going to happen is is eventually just
like everything that you do everything
else did you do in life becomes
repetitious and it just becomes natural
then putting on a condom is going to be
the same thing and that's what you're
going to keep on doing and the guys are
coming back and they're just telling us
great things you know sharing their life
experience and saying you know well you
know when I first started here I wasn't
quite sure if this was for me you know
we've lost a couple guys because of that
whole idea of well you know I don't
believe this works or you know what I
mean I don't like the ideas the
statistics the stats that are being
thrown at us I a couple of people have
made a statement while identify myself
as a gay man not an MSM you know what I
mean but the the the focus is that we
focus on them just educating ourselves
and each other and protecting ourselves
and protecting each other recently some
of the challenges that we've had a
negative response is when we're doing
outreach and like I said Tatiana is one
of those people that she'll just keep on
going at you not in a way where you're
aggravating or annoying a person but to
the point where she breaks the ice and
before you know it you're breaking out
in conversation before you know the
person is actually learning something
without even knowing that you've
interrupted their day you know what I
mean and we've proven that on being
dedicated focused will prevail if we
continue that we continue to educate
through our core group meetings and our
interventions on HIV and STD awareness
and we continue to prevail mr.
interpretations and ideas and opinions
and theories of stats like I stated
before some of the negatives that we get
from a lot of the young guys when we
talk to them and we believe and this is
very interesting because before I came
to this
format today you know I sat down at the
core group with the members of the team
and I asked them what are some things
that you feel are important or that
would it send the message that this
program works you know and as I SAT
there there were only six of us in the
room and it just happened to be one of
those days where it was nice enough that
maybe everybody just didn't want to come
in and sit down and have a good time and
talk about some real life stuff and
important thing came out of that and
they stated that they believe that if
you're looking for a legitimate
friendship versus a hookup then this
program works for you so retention how
do we keep young MSM is interested we
assure
let's see
well what we do is we assure them that
the facilitator job is to make their
ideas come alive they have to put the
work into it and an ownership is a
powerful thing and I truly believe that
the members of our core group know that
this is their program and whatever comes
out of it is because they they wanted it
to happen Silvio is doing an excellent
job like I said before and our Director
of Public Health Roseanne right and
Shane lock would have been very
supportive I know they're in the process
of working on their first annual summer
safety event where they're they chosen a
local venue where they're going to have
a sit-down dinner and presentation and
giving out awards and everything so if
you want to know more about that then
you can contact Sylvia or one of the
members in the core group another thing
that I just wanted to share as well as
that we are also working on a three
month schedule right now due to staffing
issues we're kind of short but we're
going out every Friday with the mobile
health fan and we're testing a minimum
of 10 to 15 people will pop every time
we go out and we've got together a
three-month schedule where we have 15
locations where we will be out and about
and conducting ctrs and the cool thing
about this is that the empowerment team
came to us and says you know what can we
do to assist you in this and this is how
strong and passionate they have proven
to be because of other dedication to the
program and what they do is now we set a
table outside the RV about four of us
counselors from get inside the RV and
test at a time and what they do as it
slows down a little bit if there's not
enough people out there they start
walking out into the community knocking
on doors going into the park telling
people hey you know we've got some water
we've got some snacks over here some
literature come and check out what we're
doing free counseling and testing and
from time to time we will give
incentives to the people that are doing
the CTR once again I just want to UM
just reassure you that the empowerment
program is a wonderful amazing thing
for young men and like I said we focus
on 18 to 29 one thing and that I want to
share also is that a lot of the older ms
sims are asking well what about us where
do we fit in you know what i mean so i
think this is the beginning of something
really truly amazing that we've proven
that is very effective and it works and
maybe we can broaden the horizons as
time goes on you know right now we're 18
to 29 i truly believe that that age
category is important we don't need to
mix and match the older fellows with the
younger fellows because we're all in a
different stage in life and it's
important we're not trying to make the
young guys catch up we want to them to
enjoy where they are to be happy to be
safe and be well but something that I
would love to see come to life at the
Waterbury health department so once
again I thank you very much for inviting
me to share our empowerment program and
have a good day thank you